[Music]
what a shake him in the reject nation it
is your boy John Humphrey come and ask
you to check out a brand new trailer and
today we're doing something a little
different because the new Devil May
because the new Devil May Cry 5 Dante
gameplay reveal trailer just dropped a
few days ago we were in Mexico at the
time which was rad but I wasn't able to
check this out because there was too
much going on but I'm checking it out
right now
very excited about this this is you know
we don't usually cover video games on
this channel but when we have something
to talk about we do and this is a game
franchise that I actually am really into
pick this up a number of years ago as an
offshoot of Resident Evil that just got
so different that they had to give it
its own name in its own world and yeah
I've played the first four games I
didn't play DMC the reboot game but I'm
very excited for this love the trailer
that came out of a three but before we
get into this video I want to give a
quick patron of the day shout out to my
friend actually my homegirl Tiana Hicks
Tiana just moved out to Idaho where the
potatoes grow and I'm sure nobody in
Idaho is tired of hearing about that but
Tiana super cool and she's into you know
sir horror sci-fi kind of stuff so I
thought this would be the perfect kind
of video I don't know if you play video
games but I know you might like
something like this at least the vibe of
something like this is something I could
see you enjoying Tiana actually gave me
my bed frame and a spare tire so extra
special thanks for those because I am
getting great use out of them I don't
know why I like break a tire every year
but yes Tiana thank you so much for
joining like you totally didn't have to
do that but it was like a super awesome
surprise and yeah I hope that you like
this shout out and I hope that Idaho is
treating you well yeah but anyway here
we go let's jump into this Coen shouts
out to the to the little man Aidan as
well hope he's doing good here we go
biggie 18
sorry feels like
[Music]
try not to get us killed on the way
there zero
[Music]
and heavy-metal vibe
oh wow
[Music]
okay
forgot this gameplay feels yeah like a
blend of a more cinematic style with the
brutal of waitangi
[Music]
that snarkiness
[Music]
oh is that a devil breaker I was just
reading
whoa
[Music]
honestly
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
hey Johnny don't say
[Music]
yeah whoa
kicking ass with a motorcycle
[Music]
it's kind of like platinum John wick I'm
telling ah they always give you so much
less of Dante hey ever that's good it's
a good tease that's what a good tease is
for all right so this is a pretty cool
trailer I mean this definitely made me
really excited to play the game it's
fast paced it's got that heavy-metal
vibe and you know some of those Evil
Dead flourishes but at least that's how
it comes across to me you know it's got
a tongue-in-cheek which the series has
always had I mean the you know the
opening cutscene he's like kicking ass
and eating pizza this party's getting
crazy let's rock
there's always been a cheekiness to this
series and it seems like all those tones
are in full effect here a lot of cool
creatures a lot of really beautiful
settings I was reading an article
earlier just about some of the gameplay
and things like that and they pointed
out and I agree that this sort of has a
nostalgic meets updated vibe especially
in the way they're capturing gameplay
and you can tell because I mean a lot of
the stuff in the old Devil May Cry games
I kind of remember as being a lot wider
angles you could see a lot of the room
and especially when you would jump up
and do like shooting combos or sword
combos you know the camera would kind of
punch out and this seems a lot more
closed up a lot more grounded a lot more
ground level which is interesting I mean
I think that's a cool way to go because
I've really enjoyed the tone of the
cinematic trailers for this game and
just the world look that they continue
to go for and I didn't get to play the
the remake I should say and I've seen
some trailers for and I understand that
it's not without its charms but it is a
different vibe it is nice to kind of
come back here for this especially for
me because it has been a long time since
I've like really gotten to play games
and jumping back in this year with e3
you know this got me SuperDuper excited
gonna have to get a next-gen console
cross that bridge when we get to it but
yeah I like the change of the look here
I understand they're using the re engine
that they developed for Resident Evil 7
I like the look of everything both in
terms of just how the light and the
physics appear and also the production
designs I mean you've got so many cool
creatures you've got this like Grim
Reaper
you know they always have these weird
mixtures of insect like demon like
things that evoke like porcelain dolls
and stuff gothic elements classical
elements you know really borrowing from
the mythology because you know all these
characters are named after figures from
ancient history or from literature you
know Dante obviously Nero the Emperor
and whatnot I like the look of Nico - I
like that edition she looks like a a
cool character and B you know I
understand that she's like a tech head
so I got imagine that that's gonna bring
a cool element to the game and I noticed
they're you know you've got Nero with
the prosthetic arm I also read up a
little bit on that and that seems like
it's gonna add something pretty cool to
this game because from what I understand
instead of demon bringer which you know
was like the full-on demon army now have
these demon breakers and I like the idea
that you're gonna get to switch them out
and try out new abilities with them and
things like that and that they don't
last forever apparently you know you
have to conserve and I do like a little
bit of strategy and a little bit of
friction in my games nothing I've really
complained about the fact that in the
original Devil May Cry you kind of shoot
forever and hack forever but I do like
the idea that you would have to
strategize a little bit based around
that I mean I don't know exactly how
they're gonna change any of the other
mechanics and you know you got your
trusty sword here and I love that that
you take that one step further from the
motorcycle handle you got Dante just
kicking ass with his actual motorcycle
which just seems like a perfectly Devil
May Cry upgrade for this because a it's
a gnarly looking bike and it's the kind
of thing Dante would probably ride and
also like of course it's a weapon why
not you know and I like that they blend
it in a little bit of a cinematic
through line just with a couple of these
interstitial shots they chose just to
give this particular trailer kind of a
flow that I appreciated between all the
mayhem from the actual game plan it
looks like these are the gameplay
graphics for the most part except for
you know maybe at the very top but yeah
you know between this and the original
debut trailer I am super excited for
this I cannot wait to get back into this
world this is this is a game that I'm
really excited to see come into the
modern you know the newest generation of
consoles and whatnot so I know this got
me really excited to play again and I
really hope and that Greg and I can get
our hands on a next-gen console because
this new crop games
looks really really cool not only this
but a lot of stuff we checked out at e3
as well so thank you guys for tuning in
that's all I got for now there's
anything you caught that I missed or
anything you want to talk about heads up
in the comment box below and as always
you can subscribe to the Rio rejects
ring that notification bell to get
updated every time a review or a video
is out because I guess why will why
wouldn't the subscribe button notify
people that you've never mind it also
check us out on patreon we got a ton of
cool stuff over there TV show watch
Long's weekly few days behind the scenes
stuff great community as well so come on
over check us out of there if you are so
inclined and I will see you on the next
one party people Cheers